c'est à la main et en équipe comme on
peut que les secours s'organisent à
crement Chuck c'est une scène de fin du
monde
les pompiers départ des civils
complètement dépassé par l'ampleur de ce
qui a toutes les allures d'une attaque
venue des airs sans aucun préavis
à l'intérieur on peut entendre les
secouristes chercher des survivants
aveuglés par la poussière et les cendres
on ignore combien sont morts combien ont
brûlé vif englouti par les flammes
car il était à peine 16h et le centre
commercial était achalandé selon les
autorités quand deux explosions ont été
entendues et ressentis
que j'ai été jeté au sol avec mon petit
dans les bras de cette femme
alors qu'on sort les blessés 1 à 1 et
avec beaucoup de difficultés
c'est complètement surréal cet homme
sous le choc il ne reste presque plus
rien du centre commercial
il faut dégager les grandes structures
pour sauver les femmes et les enfants
qui sont coincés à l'intérieur Diane
tonne de lachenko il est un des
conseillers du ministre des Affaires
intérieures qui est venu constater de
ses propres yeux ce que le président
voit le dîner ski qualifie d'actes
terroristes effrontés
[Musique]
jusqu'ici épargné outre cette usine
d'entretien de véhicules juste à côté du
centre commercial elle n'avait aucune
valeur stratégique a déclaré le
président depuis Kiev la capitale il
venait d'ailleurs tout juste de plaider
sa cause et de demander où G7 qu'on lui
fournisse des systèmes de défense
antimissiles quand cette attaque est
survenue
selon la défense ukrainienne deux
missile à longue portée lancée depuis la
Russie sont en cause sur ces images que
nous n'avons pas pu authentifier on peut
voir le premier quelques secondes avant
l'impact une horreur absolue un geste
ignoble a écrit le président de la
France en publiant une vidéo de lattaque
en ajoutant le peuple russe doit avoir
la vérité
dénoncé l'attaque
mais la Russie rejette tout blâme comme
elle l'a fait pour la plupart des
bombardements qui semblent viser les
civils depuis le début de la guerre ce
soir à Clemenceau les sirènes crient en
guise de méfiance alors qu'on cherche
encore dans la ferraille et les
décombres et le bilan continue de
s'alourdir